after tunneling through the rabbit hole
Alice found herself in a dark ocean it
was dark
until she spotted some strange creatures
swimming around they were in fact
photons packets of energy emitted from
an atom they were different colors
depending on how excited they were to
have escaped the clutches of their home
atom they swam a synchronous dance a
backstroke of oscillating electric and
magnetic fields lighting up the ocean
Alice washed up near a ring of even more
curious creatures orbiting around a dodo
from listening to the dodo speak Alice
concluded that he must be very dense the
creatures were electrons and seemed to
dance in a very particular pattern
around the dodo every now and then waves
would wash over and fill the space when
this happened the creatures would become
indistinguishable from the waves in fact
everything in this world seemed to
behave like both particles and waves at
times emerging from the sea
Alice was sad to find herself too weak
to join the dance no matter how fast she
tried to run she just couldn't keep up
that was until a kind bird gave her a
ride on his beak propping her up to a
lower energy level where she could
comfortably join in that's when the
white rabbit appeared again flying in on
a tailspin he looked like he was going
somewhere important so Alice emitted
herself from the dance and followed
after them both lighting up the forest
as they went